[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and with the
wall-crawler making his way across the
world in more ways than one it's time to
break down whether this new movie is a
home run or not throughout this video
I'll be discussing everything that you
need to know about spider-man far from
home as well as what it's ending means
and what it teases for the future of
phase 4 there will be heavy spoilers so
if you haven't seen the movie yet then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
with that out the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video I hope you enjoy it and now sit
back relax and let's get to my breakdown
of spider-man far from home far from
home picks up immediately after the
events of Avengers endgame with the
world mourning the loss of Iron Man
after he sacrificed himself to save the
universe the film itself opens with Nick
Fury and Maria Hill are finding
themselves caught in the eye of the
storm with a face and about to hit the
dirt literally when they go up against
the earth elemental however after they
are saved out of nowhere by Mysterio it
seems like the world is finally in safe
hands on the surface Mysterio is the
perfect replacement for Tony and he's
more than willing to take on the
position as the planets best protector
in stark contrast excuse the pun Peter
isn't sure whether he still wants to
deal with the responsibility that comes
with his great power every chance he
gets he tries to ghost Nick Fury and
whilst he's happy still wearing the suit
it's clear that he's not ready to become
the Next Iron Man however his powers are
much sought after and when fury tracks
him down during the middle of a school
trip through Europe he slowly comes to
the realization that he has to become
the next Tony Stark
what I love about this acceptance is
that Peter first gets a real hint of how
he must look at the world when wearing
Tony's glasses and this begins to make
him understand that this is more than
just about him and that when the earth
is in danger he has to answer the call
that doesn't mean it's an easy ride
though and along the way peer teams up
with Quentin Beck aka Mysterio who
becomes somewhat of a mentor to the
impressionable team that puts a wealth
of doubt in his mind as to whether he's
cut out for the hero life or not
apparently comes from the multiverse and
was transported to our timeline it due
to the snap which tore through reality
on his world the elementals ravaged the
planet it seems like Bek selflessly
wants to stop the same thing from
happening here however if you have even
a passing interest in spider-man then
you probably knew from the first trailer
that the elementals would be fake and
that Mysterio is in fact the bad guy
orchestrating the entire attack for fame
and fortune we learn that back as a
master of illusions and was an ex stock
industries employee that helped the
create both the augmented reality
simulation from Captain America Civil
War that he has been using to cast a
shadow in Peters mind we discovered that
the multiverse at least for now doesn't
exist and that Bek was fired for being
unstable in the wake of Stark's death he
finally sees an opportunity to rise to
the forefront and Peter unearths this
during the movie what I love about the
villain is that it once again showcases
the depth of stocks failure ever since
the first Iron Man film the majority of
enemies in the MCU have been brought
forth due to Tony's a responsibility and
spider-man slowly learns that though he
must follow in his mentors footsteps
it's imperative that he doesn't make the
same mistakes it's also in this movie
that Peters relationship with MJ really
comes to fruition and after the stellar
performance by zendaya and Holland it's
clear to see why they are Marvel's new
golden couple the two put it together
that Bek is faking it and though the
hero goes to face down his new
arch-nemesis he also has to battle with
his self-doubt that Mysterio expertly
put into his mind
what's masterful about the manipulator
is that he really makes Peter not only
doubt himself but also those around him
but Peter realizes that he must rebuild
himself which really manifests with him
creating a new suit that comes across as
one of the coolest that he's worn in the
film franchise so far it's in this scene
that I really felt like Peter stepped
into the role of the new Iron Man as a
co-star creating a suit in the cave from
the very first film
Peter rushes to London to take back
head-on who once again is attempting to
unleash an illusion however Peter stops
him and Mysterio seemingly dies but
whether this is actually the case is
another thing entirely Mysterio is of
course a master of illusion and upon
realizing that he's unable to beat Peter
I can definitely see him instead
faking his death in order to get out of
the situation bear in mind Beth takes
control of stocks tech in the film so
he's more than capable of making it
appear that he's dead the only thing
that confirms that he's no longer alive
is the machine that he himself had
control over and it's pretty safe to
assume that he had a contingency plan
built into the AI and case he needed to
get out of the situation to me you don't
cast Jake Gyllenhaal as you big bad to
kill him off in the first film and I can
genuinely see him returning which i
think is confirmed by the post-credits
scene which I'll get into next so the
film wraps up neatly Peter and MJ look
like they're in love and things go back
to the status quo until both characters
swing into the post-credits scene the
first scene picks up with Peter gliding
through New York with MJ and after he
drops her off and leaps to a lamp post
overlooking Madison Square Garden we see
on a large screen that there's an
incoming news report from the Daily
Bugle they've apparently acquired an
exclusive clip that shows spider-man was
in fact behind the drone attack in
London and is a threat to the world
rather than its hero the show is hosted
by none other than Jay jonah Jameson
played by JK Simmons and whilst this is
an amazing moment it's quickly sent
bittersweet when the media mogul reveals
the second part of the footage that
shows that Peter Parker is spider-man
Peter is devastated but just before we
can see the repercussions of this reveal
the movie cuts to black similar to the
ending of homecoming in which Aunt May
discover that her nephew is the webhead
so what could happen going forward well
if you're a fan of the comic books then
you'll know that this reveal to the
world already happened in the pages of
Civil War with Peters identity out in
the open his enemies quickly close in on
him but after they realized he's very
difficult to kill they instead go after
his friends and family an assassin
shoots Aunt May and the story becomes
about Peter tracking down the shooter
and getting to the root of the hit which
is revealed to be the kingpin well I
don't think that the MC will bring this
in it's very possible that in this
incarnation Mysterio could still be
pulling the strings after all it seems
likely that the villain edited and gave
the fudge to Jameson to broadcast to the
world whilst I've seen a lot of people
angry that Peters identity has been
revealed so early the MCU is no stranger
to the heroes having public faces and
this has pretty
being a staple of the universe since the
first film in 2008 however in the comics
the creators behind them did wreck on
the reveal and after Peter made a deal
with Mephisto that altered reality he
was able to become anonymous once more
in the storyline one more day Peter was
able to return to the life of a masked
hero however in exchange he lost the
love of his life Mary Jane what else
does credit scene does is that it
confirms the multiverse with a slightly
altered version of Jameson appearing in
this universe as opposed to the Raimi
set of fillers if j jonah Jameson is a
constant year then that means that there
could also exist alternate versions of
the character and Holland and Garfield
have recently confirmed that they would
both love to do a live action version of
into the spider-verse
if Sony managed to secure Tobey Maguire
for this then it could easily be the
best spider-man movie of all time with
all three leads heading up the film it
would be interesting to see if Marvel
adapts this and if they do how they
rework the story to fit a return it gets
me really hyped for the future of the
franchise and I can't wait to see what
happens down the line especially with
the next reveal the second scene starts
off with Nick Fury and Maria Hill are
driving along before they transform into
Scrolls which are none other than Talos
and his wife from Captain Marvel this
means that and far from home the two
shield agents have in fact been Scrolls
the entire time and we discovered that
the real hill in Fury or in fact on
vacation aboard a Skrull spaceship we've
had confirmation from Kevin Feige that
the alien race would once again return
to the Marvel Universe and I have a
feeling that we will definitely get more
from them than just a credit scene at
this point in the MCU it's been 30 years
since the events of Captain Marvel and
it doesn't look like the scrolls have
finally found a home yet in the story
Secret Invasion they invade the planet
and assume the identities of several
heroes in order to achieve their goals
now that the alien race are in orbit of
the planet I can definitely see some of
them going rogue and trying to take over
the earth whilst the Avengers are still
dissembled if we get that it'll be
amazing but either way this really gets
me excited for what's to come down the
line now before we get into my review I
just want to let you know that we're
giving away a free copy of Avengers
endgame to one lucky winner and all you
have to do is like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts and the movie
the comments below the winner will be
chosen at random on August the 10th and
the blu-ray will be shipped out from
then to whoever gets the prize best of
luck to everyone who takes part now
let's get into the rest of the video so
what did I think of the movie overall
well far from home it's outstanding from
start to finish and really feels like
the perfect follow-up to endgame
this brings the storyline back down to
ground level and sets up several things
that I know will have bigger
consequences down the line it's one of
those movies that you walk out of and
want to find out what happens next as
soon as you can every actor brings their
a-game and this movie is really doing
its all to flesh out the Spidey verse in
more ways than one
I really hope the next film is set in
Australia and called spider-man Home &
Away but even if it's not I feel like
this movie ticked all of the boxes and
that's why it gets a 9 out of 10
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on far from home and where you think the
universe will go from here comment below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video then please like it and make sure
that you check out my full breakdown of
the Avengers end game we release new
footage which will be linked at the end
it covers all of the ins and outs of the
added scenes and it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know what
happens without paying more money to see
the same movie twice I'll link that at
the end and hopefully I'll see you over
there after this this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like
could subscribe thanks again for taking
the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best and I'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]